right so I don't normally do unboxing
videos but
box just arrived and I have a fair idea
of what it is and so I thought I'd
better
unbox this I've started the unboxing
process I've removed
sort of the paper and some of box one
from what I've got but
uh books the unboxing is about to occur
this is in many ways
uh the most expensive book I've ever
bought and it's the most expensive book
I've ever bought because I wanted it to
exist
and uh many years ago I think back in
2009 so 13 years ago
Ron Drummond came over to me at the
world science fiction convention
and explained that
uh the book had been in process and then
the printer had collapsed and basically
taken all the money with them as they
collapsed
and um
and the project needed rescuing and it
needed rescuing essentially by a
donation
and while I wasn't the only person who
donated
I was one of the main
people who got to carry this project
forward and they did it because I love
the book which is John Crowley's book
little big
which I think is just one of the most
incredible books the 20th century
and I also did it
[Music]
um
because I
loved the idea of
being able to hold one in my hand and of
the people who had subscribed to the
book
being able to hold it in their hands
um it was originally meant to be the
25th Anniversary Edition
it is now coming out as the 40th
anniversary edition and I'm
excited and with no further Ado
first of all First Impressions before
even opening it properly
is it's really heavy and second
impression is it's really thick okay so
unboxing about to happen
[Applause]
unfolding the Box
here is a copy an advanced copy of
Little Big
fairies Parliament
by Peter Melton afterward
it's like how it bloom
and
I will pull out my little cutter
cut
gently
cellophane
around the book
[Applause]
and my copy is in green
and
huge
and
very haunting
gosh
for illustrations on the day
um
and it has
a thing by Neil Gaiman
which is a kind of tiny
introduction that I wrote
and there are
I know that I'm not the only one who
wrote one of these introductions so
there are another two of them out there
I won't tell you who wrote them
they could do
um
and
it's
gorgeous
one of my problems with little big
has been
copies of the book have always been to
small
the type was too small the way they were
put together were too small and this
is
gorgeous
on a certain day in June 19 something
the young man was making his way on foot
northward from the great City to a town
or place called Edgewood
that he had been told of but had never
visited
his name was Smokey barnable he was
going to Edgewood to get married
the fact that he walked and didn't ride
was one of the conditions placed and is
coming there at all
and um
it's gorgeous it's beautiful now I just
want to take it away
let me read it it is how many pages
661.
so let's
over 700 pages
and uh
a little big project
has happened
um
it's the author's preferred text of the
novel
beautiful
and I was never 100
000 sure it would ever exist
I don't think
any of us were but it exists it's
beautiful and
um
if you're one of the people
who is waiting for your copy who paid
for it at some point
sure
that you get in touch
with inconabular
and you let them know
that what your current address is how to
get it to you and so forth there are I
think three or four hundred copies left
for sale
um
that weren't already spoken for and uh
you want one
again order it now it's not cheap
but
um
they will soon all be gone and then the
prices will only go up
right there we go it's so cool
little big
25th Anniversary Edition
printed on the 40th anniversary